the Royal College of Nursing the nurses
Union used to be avowedly anti-strike
action
not anymore its members now feel they
have no choice I think the pace is
ridiculous basically over time with
inflation you can see that your pay is
actually decreasing and with the cost of
living crisis as well it's just another
and another added pressure nurses are
doing extra shifts Bank shifts we call
it to make ends meet but that ends up
mean that you're more exhausted because
you're already doing your normal shifts
it wasn't long ago that nurses were
applauded on doorsteps up and down the
country for their work saving lives
during the pandemic now they're quitting
in record numbers
[Music]
because clapping as they chant doesn't
pay the rent and nor does the four
percent pay rise currently on the table
the nurses are demanding substantially
more as much as 19 to make up they say
for years of low pay that's failed to
keep up with inflation the government
says the money just isn't there to give
the nurses what they want as well as
giving the National Health Service what
it needs to survive you can't have one
without the other the nurses say and
unless the government engages in Pay
talks in the coming days they warn
there'll be more of this in the new year
so I think because it's come to a point
where it's an existential threat our
shortages and the collapse of morale in
the NHS it's an existential threat to
the future of the NHS we are now
committed to fighting not just for
decent pay in our pocket but are a
sustainable NHS where people can afford
old to live and work in a capital city
like London opinion polls suggest the
public are on the nurse's side
[Music]
putting their support despite the
inevitable disruption being caused to
non-urgent patient care and that's
uncomfortable for the government
determined not to give in to striking
workers while increasingly being blamed
for bringing the National Health Service
to the verge of collapse Jonah Hull Al
Jazeera London